everyone out there what's going on
welcome in to another edition of Market
takes I am Dion Robert Bowen your host
reporter here with the Wall Street
Journal and uh we are doing a look ahead
looking out to some of the very
important very key data economic data
that we're going to be getting this week
and just talking about how that is
likely to affect the market because this
week is is one of the biggest weeks that
I think we've seen in a long time
especially after the big sell-off that
we got in stocks uh the moves that we
got in the bond market and and all that
really across markets last week in
response to that jobs number uh you saw
the U.S economy added 263 000 jobs
minimal revision slightly better than
expected but the market did not take
that well and so as we come into this
week we have a really consequential week
in terms of a number of data reports
they're going to tell us a lot about
inflation and about the US economy right
now we're in this
interesting place where you know bad
news is good news and all that you know
people talk about it but I want to break
down just kind of what that means and
why that is uh because really the market
has kind of gotten into its head at this
point that the Federal Reserve is going
to keep raising rates until they see
inflation break that they're not going
to kind of reverse course the way that a
lot of folks were predicting we saw a
bit of the beginning of last week this
kind of relief rally okay things are
getting worse in the economic fronts the
fed's not going to have to do as much
and then that jobs report was kind of
what broke the spirit or broke the back
of the market because it showed that you
know what hiring continues wages
continue to grow the economy is intact
and now you've got an interesting sort
of situation where you're going to see a
lot of folks hoping for Worse data
hoping that you know the economy maybe
does break so the Federal Reserve
doesn't have to continue tightening
monetary policy and making it more
difficult to borrow money for businesses
to grow Etc et cetera so we're going to
dive into all the data that you can
expect this week we have five big
reports that are coming out five reports
not all of all of them would normally be
a big deal for the market but I think
this week especially if you get to if
you see some differences in some of the
reports some of these other smaller less
watched and less followed reports are
going to be big this week so we're going
to talk about the Consumer Price Index
as well as the producer price index we
get both of those this week on Wednesday
and Thursday also going to talk about
the U.S retail sales report that one's
going to be big and if that wasn't
enough we are wrapping up the week with
the consumer sentiment index from the
University of Michigan I think consumer
sentiment is going to be something that
the market is going to be really keyed
into and tied into and we're also going
to break down what to expect from the
import export price report that's going
to kind of give us a look forward at
what inflation could be doing and how
it's moving and I'm going to talk about
each one of those individual usually and
what they could mean collectively for
the market so look let's start with
what's become the most widely watched
piece of data in the market that is the
Consumer Price Index for September
that's coming out on Thursday CPI CPI
day Thursday is going to be a big one
economists are predicting that CPI Rose
8.1 percent in September and 0.2 percent
month over month that 8.1 percent
year-over-year number now that number is
really important because we economists
think that we stayed above eight percent
it means you know that's a number of
months over eight percent inflation that
we're not breaking that number yet if we
break through and we get below eight
percent even though you know seven point
nine percent would still be high
historically very high that would
suggest that we are seeing inflation
start to break through important
psychological barriers and that it's
falling in in the way that the Federal
Reserve wants it to uh and that they
really feel like they need it to in
order for them to slow their role and
kind of chill with all the hikes on
inflation if the it is higher than 8.1
and particularly if it's higher than 8.3
percent where it was in August that year
over year number you could expect to and
you should expect to see a big time
Market sell-off
within the data you've also got the core
CPI now that's been moving in the
opposite direction even as CPI has kind
of come down from nine percent where it
was uh in August or sorry in in July
even though CPI has come down from where
it was earlier in the year when it
peaked up at nine percent in June not
July and June uh we are seeing that core
CPI number start to tick higher and
that's because of Housing and because of
food particularly food you buy at the
grocery store those things are eaten
into people's pocketbooks and that's the
thing the Federal Reserve really looks
at and if they see that tick higher even
as overall inflation and headline
inflation as they call it is moving
lower well that could be cause for more
concern on the market so watch that core
number that's expected to be 6.5 percent
up from 6.3 percent in August watch that
core number that's going to be big we've
started to hear talk that maybe
inflation hasn't peaked from the Federal
Reserve Vice chair Leo Brainerd said in
a speech at the end of September this is
a worry that the Federal Reserve has
that they're not seeing inflation Peak
and that maybe it could even go up above
that nine percent number so that's
something big to keep in mind and to
watch for
as you're watching out for that Consumer
Price Index number on Thursday the day
before we get PPI the producer price
index that number has been kind of
consistently moving lower uh that could
also move the market in anticipation for
CPI the next day that's expected to be
8.3 percent down from 8.7 percent we are
seeing PPI wholesale prices producer
prices essentially what businesses are
paying for the inputs and things they
buy to produce the goods that you and I
who are consumers buy those numbers are
ticking down and what the hope is is
that producers because they're seeing
the effect of inflation will start to
mark down those price increases maybe
increase by a little less uh in hopes
that that then those declines in
producer prices get passed on the
consumers businesses are still CL still
clearly passing those price increases
onto consumers even bigger again we keep
seeing that in the earnings data that
businesses are marking up prices more
than the pace of inflation so if the
pace for their Nation PPI comes down we
hope to see that in the consumer prices
the the big report that we're going to
get on Friday U.S retail sales now this
is normally a big report in its own
right it's going to be even bigger if we
see declines on CPI and PPI or increases
in CPI and PPI that retail sales report
is going to be huge it's normally just
thought of about as looking at the
health of the economy I think for this
month it's also going to be about
inflation if retail sales is strong
that's going to mean that inflation has
not abated also again folks in the
market are looking for a recession you
know you want to see the data start to
cool down notably and start to really
you know fall off a bit that that sounds
strange you normally don't want the
economy or you want the economy to be
healthy you don't want to see you know
staggering or really low retail sales
this month is a month where I think if
retail sales is too high or too strong
you could see a big sell-off in the
market especially if we've seen High CPI
and Pi PPI so keep your eyes on that U.S
best retail sales report on Friday
especially after you know if we've seen
a big Market pickup or a big market
decline after CPI and PPI watch that
retail sales report that could throw the
whole thing in the garbage completely
change the narrative a lot like we saw
last week with the jobs report
um last thing also on Friday sorry not
the last thing second to last thing the
penultimate thing if you will we get the
export import data for September that's
also on Friday Friday is going to be a
big day because we could see a lot of
the momentum built up this week kind of
change move or if we see that retail
sales report and the export import data
move in a similar Direction which is
down the market wants to see these
things all come down wants to see these
things all getting weaker that export
import price that's going to tell us its
decline for two straight months is
expected to decline for a third straight
month if we get that I think you could
see a very strong Market reaction
because it will likely signal that
inflation is coming down the amount of
money that we're paying to import Goods
to the US and the amount of money we're
paying we're getting when we export
goods talks about the the health of the
global economy overall what prices are
doing how they're moving that's going to
be a report that I think really on the
margins could move things but if it
moves in the same directions the other
data if it corroborates the story that
export import number is going to be big
last but not least the actual last
report that I think is going to be
important for this week is going to be
the University of Michigan's consumer
sentiment index for October so these
these numbers that we've talked about
are all looking backwards CPI PPI export
import prices retail sales all looking
backwards at September consumer
sentiment is going to look at October
and it's a survey that the University of
Michigan does it's much more concurrent
what's happening now really I think the
market wants to see consumers a little
worried a little concerned backing off
of making more purchases especially big
purchases the details of that report are
going to be big
if in terms of if we are going into a
recession or if consumers still feel
good and can go out there and buy things
and you know they may be feeling a
little bit down about inflation but we
saw this number start to pick up from
that June number from when we got the
lowest level on record for the consumer
sentiment index and it picked up until
last month it was still higher than the
month before but the second reading kind
of was lower than the first and now
we're expecting to see consumers getting
worried losing confidence and and that
number moving lower I think that might
drive the market higher if we see that
in concert with these other reports that
we get on Friday so to wrap it all up
you got PPI on Wednesday that's going to
give us the first look at what inflation
could be the market hasn't had anything
to really chew on or won't have a lot to
chew on except for fed speakers and some
minimal data up till that Wednesday PPI
producer price index number that can
move the market Thursday CPI that's the
big one baby that's the big deal and
then we get on Friday you get these
three reports export import data you get
U.S retail sales which is going to be
the big one and of course that consumer
sentiment index from University of
Michigan all on Friday each one of those
could move the market in a big way so
watch out and make sure you're parsing
through the details I won't be here with
you I'm gonna be taking advantage of
that strong dollar going to Europe
trying to you know get that one-to-one
or even better than one to one the
strongest value for the dollar in about
20 years but keep watching and we will
be back with you uh in late October to
keep breaking down this data hope you
got everything you needed for Market
takes I know you could have been
anywhere in the world but you're here
with me and I appreciate you for doing
that and we will see you when we are
back from Europe hopefully I don't come
back broke I got a little bit of money
left and don't get too excited about
that one to one uh dollar to Euro but we
will be with you next time and I hope to
see you then